[Musik]
[Applaus]
schöner nehmen beruf den ich habe ist
dass man hier ein einmaliges bauwerk hat
und dass man hier tolle übersicht hat
also hier in dieser höhe ist noch nicht
sehr oft die technik ist hier anders
alles einmalig und das ist schon der 368
meter hoch mehr als 30.000 tonnen schwer
und von fast überall in der stadt zu
sehen
das ist der berliner fernsehturm ein
wahrzeichen und ein publikumsmagnet
60 millionen besucher hatte der berliner
fernsehturm seit seiner eröffnung am
dritten oktober 1969
schon etwas unheimlich ich dachte nicht
dass es so hoch ist
wir haben orte gesucht die wir besuchen
können den fernsehturm haben wir als
erstes gesehen
man sieht jede sehenswürdigkeit berlins
mit einem blick wir sind als touristen
in berlin und da muss man einfach auf
den fernsehturm gehen
zwei aufzüge bringen die turm besucher
in 40 sekunden nach oben
wer mag kann jetzt wirtschaft schauen
mit 21 kilometern pro stunde geht es zur
aussichtsetage in 203 metern höhe ist
einfach eine sehr interessante arbeit
wir haben besucher aus der ganzen welt
jeden tag neue gäste die sich das
berliner wahrzeichen anschauen möchten
maximal 350 personen gleichzeitig dürfen
aus sicherheitsgründen hier oben sein
[Musik]
bei gutem wetter können sie bis zu 80 km
weit sehen
[Musik]
im restaurant eine drehbare
aussichtsplattform die gäste fahren
während ihrer mahlzeit im kreis
[Musik]
man kommt hier rein die tische bewegen
sich man fängt erst mal an seinen tisch
zu suchen und meines erst mal verblüfft
von der aussicht die die einen hier oben
erwartet und ja das ist schon was
besonderes
1965 baubeginn und nach nur vier jahren
ist der fernsehturm fertig im geteilten
deutschland ein prestige objekt der ddr
führung
heute wahrzeichen des wiedervereinigten
landes und seiner hauptstadt
torsten brinkmann arbeitet seit 1994
hier und kommt dahin wo sonst niemand
hin kommt von der antennen plattform in
246 metern höhe gibt es eine einmalige
aussicht über berlin bis heute ist der
turm eine wichtige funktion für
fernsehen und radio
findet auch architektonisch gelungen und
vor allen dingen sehr schöne sehr
wertvolle ingenieursleistung also was
die kollegen sich hier damals ausgedacht
haben mit rechenschieber und tafelberg
sozusagen das ist doch alles sehr
bemerken zu haben der berliner
fernsehturm nicht nur ein
touristenmagnet sondern ein bauwerk das
von der teilung deutschlands und seiner
wiedervereinigung mit erzählt